>>> ANOTHER TOP TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL WILL BE
TESTIFYING TODAY.
THIS TIME IT'S THE FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
CNN'S SARA MURRAY, SHE'S
TRACKING THIS FOR US AT THIS
HOUR.
SARA, WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT
POMPEO'S TESTIMONY AND WHAT THEY
COULD BE GOING OVER?
>> Reporter: WELL, HE'S EXPECTED
TO APPEAR TODAY, AND OBVIOUSLY
HE HELD SIGNIFICANT POSITIONS IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AS THE
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR, LEADING THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY HAVE
REALLY FOCUSED ON WITH THESE
HIGH RANKING OFFICIALS IS WHAT
THE DISCUSSIONS WERE AROUND
JANUARY 6th AND AFTERWARDS,
PARTICULARLY ABOUT THE 25th
AMENDMENT.
YOU KNOW, THIS MOVE TO
POTENTIALLY TRY TO OUST DONALD
TRUMP FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY HAVE REALLY WANTED TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF WITH SOME OF
THESE HIGH RANKING OFFICIALS,
WHO, FRANKLY, HAD A LOT OF
CONCERN AFTER WHAT THEY SAW ON
JANUARY 6th.
YOU KNOW, WE KNOW THAT A HANDFUL
OF HIGH RANKING OFFICIALS HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN WITH THE
COMMITTEE, STEVE MNUCHIN, THE
TREASURY SECRETARY.
WE KNOW THEY SPOKE TO MICK
MULVANEY WHO WAS A SPECIAL ENVOY
TO NORTHERN IRELAND, AND YOU
KNOW, HE RESIGNED AFTER JANUARY
6th.
WE KNOW THEY SPOKE TO EUGENE
SCALIA, WHO WAS THE LABOR
SECRETARY AND HIGHLIGHTED SOME
OF THEIR TESTIMONY IN THE
HEARINGS, HIM EXPLAINING TO
DONALD TRUMP THAT HE THOUGHT
THAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT SHOULD
CONCEDE AFTER HE LOST.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY REALLY
WANT TO TRY TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF WITH MIKE POMPEO, WHAT THE
SENTIMENT WAS AROUND JANUARY 6th
AND AFTERWARDS AND WHAT THE
CONCERNS WERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU, SARA.
BACK WITH ME NOW, KAITLAN
COLLINS, PAUL CALLAN AND CNN'S
DANA BASH.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE 25th
AMENDMENT, WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU ABOUT WHERE THE COMMITTEE
IS -- WHAT PATH THE COMMITTEE IS
HEADED DOWN NOW AS IT'S NOW KIND
OF ENTERING THIS NEXT CHAPTER.
>> SO MUCH OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
ABOUT CONNECTING THE DOTS AND
GIVING NEW INFORMATION AND
TESTIMONY ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN THE PAST ON JANUARY
6th AND WHAT IT MEANS FOR DONALD
TRUMP AS -- AS A PRESIDENT.
LOOKING AT THE 25th AMENDMENT
AND THE NOTION THAT SOME OF HIS
CABINET MEMBERS WERE EFFECTIVELY
THINKING ABOUT OR TALKING ABOUT
THE IDEA THAT HE WAS SO
DANGEROUS THAT THEY SHOULD
INVOKE SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT
BEEN AND GET RID OF HIM RIGHT
THEN AND THERE IS A QUESTION OF
LOOKING AHEAD.
>> IT'S A QUESTION OF LOOKING
AHEAD TO WHETHER OR NOT HE
SHOULD BE PRESIDENT AGAIN.
IT'S ALSO FOR HISTORY SAKE, BUT
IT'S BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS ISN'T JUST HISTORY,
THIS IS ABOUT THE FUTURE.
>> YEAH, AND KAITLYN ALSO BEING
BROUGHT BEFORE THE COMMITTEE IS
THE CURRENT REPUBLICAN NOMINEE
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR IN
PENNSYLVANIA, DOUG MASTRIANO,
HE'S GIVING AN INTERVIEW WITH
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
WE'LL SEE WHAT, IF ANYTHING, HE
SAYS AND GIVES TO THE COMMITTEE,
BUT WHAT ARE THE CHANCES THAT HE
TRIES TO USE THIS TO HIS
ADVANTAGE IN A RACE WHERE HE
NEEDS A TRUMP BASE TO TURN OUT
IN A BIG WAY, KIND OF JUMPS OFF
OUR CONVERSATION IN THE LAST
BLOCK.
>> IT DIDN'T PAPPEAR THAT THAT
APPEARANCE YIELDED MUCH
INFORMATION.
OF COURSE OUR COLLEAGUES HAD
BEEN REPORTING, SARAH AND ZACK,
ABOUT THE IDEA HE WASN'T
EXPECTED TO SAY MUCH BECAUSE
THERE WAS A HUGE DISAGREEMENT
OVER HOW THAT INTERVIEW WAS
BEING CONDUCTED.
HE HAD HIS OWN RECORDING AND
ACCOUNTING OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
THAT INTERVIEW.
WE KNOW THE COMMITTEE ITSELF HAS
BEEN TAPING THEM AS WE'VE SEEN
FROM MANY OF THE HEARINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN AIRING.
IT APPEARS THEY COULD NOT COME
TO AN AGREEMENT ON THAT FRONT.
I DO THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR MASTRIANO THAT THE
COMMITTEE LIKELY HAD ABOUT THE
EFFORTS THAT HE SPEARHEADED TO
TRY TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
REMEMBER, THERE WAS THAT HEARING
THAT HE HELD JUST A FEW WEEKS
AFTER THE ELECTION HAD ENDED.
HE HELPED CHARTER BUSES TO THE
JANUARY 6th RALLY AT THE
CAPITOL, AT THE ELLIPSE, AND
THEN ALSO HE WAS IN CHARGE FOR
TECHNICALLY A LITTLE BIT OF THE
AUDIT THAT THEY WERE CONDUCTING.
I USE AUDIT IN QUOTATION MARKS,
OF COURSE, SINCE THEY SAID THAT
THERE WAS NO FRAUD, WIDESPREAD
FRAUD THAT HAPPENED THERE.
THAT JUST SHOWS, THOUGH, THE
LEVEL OF HOW WIDESPREAD THIS IS.
THESE ARE TRUMP ALLIES, NOT JUST
PEOPLE LIKE MIKE POMPEO AND
THOSE IN THE CABINET AT THE
TIME, BUT IT'S ALSO THESE
OFFICIALS WHO WERE SPREAD OUT
THROUGHOUT STATES WHO HAVE A LOT
OF SWAY AND SIGNIFICANCE WHEN IT
COMES TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CAST DOUBT PUBLICLY ON THE
RESULTS OF AN ELECTION.
>> YEAH, AND SPEAKING OF ANOTHER
INVESTIGATION UNDERWAY, PAUL, IN
GEORGIA RUDY GIULIANI IS NOW
ASKING TO POSTPONE HIS TESTIMONY
TO THE GEORGIA GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATING 2020 ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HE'S GOING AT
HERE?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT THIS
GEORGIA INVESTIGATION IS VERY
DANGEROUS TO GIULIANI, AND I
THINK IT'S ALSO VERY DANGEROUS
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS THE INVESTIGATION THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE FARTHEST ALONG
IN ITS DEVELOPMENT, AND
GIULIANI'S JUST TRYING TO STALL
THE INVESTIGATION, I THINK, AND
PUSH IT OFF AS FAR AS POSSIBLE.
>> WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH BENEFIT
THAT BRINGS HIM.
DANA, ALSO AS FIRST REPORTED ON
CNN IN ANOTHER WRINKLE OF THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE, TWO YEARS
WORTH OF TEXT MESSAGES FROM THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIST ALEX JONES,
THEY'VE JUST BEEN TURNED OVER TO
THE COMMITTEE.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ABOUT THIS?
I MEAN, WHAT NEW AVENUE COULD
THIS POTENTIALLY OPEN UP FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
>> IT'S ABOUT PLANNING.
ALEX JONES WENT BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE AND DIDN'T SAY
ANYTHING.
HE INVOKED HIS FIFTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THEY GOT
MUCH FROM HIM IN THEIR
INTERVIEW.
THIS IS A TREASURE-TROVE
POTENTIALLY, IF HE HAS TWO YEARS
WORTH OF TEXTS AND THERE IS A
FAIR AMOUNT DEALING WITH JANUARY
6th OR EVEN JUST A LITTLE BIT
K
DEALING WITH JANUARY 6th.
WE KNOW HIS ROLE BECAUSE WE'VE
HEARD IT PUBLICLY.
THEY WERE VERY -- HE WAS VERY
OPEN ABOUT IT ON HIS VARIOUS
MEDIA PLATFORMS, HIS ROLE IN
STOKING AND ENCOURAGING THE
INSURRECTION.
HE WAS THERE.
HE DIDN'T GO INTO THE BUILDING,
BUT HE WAS VERY MUCH PART OF
AMPLIFYING WHAT WAS GOING ON.
>> AND PAUL, LIKE, THIS IS SO
UNUSUAL ABOUT THIS SITUATION IN
PARTICULAR IS THAT HOW THIS CAME
ABOUT IS THE ATTORNEY FOR THE
NEW TOWN FAMILIES WHO JUST WON A
CIVIL SUIT AGAINST JONES.
THIS ATTORNEY IS THE PERSON WHO
IS TURNING OVER THIS -- THESE
TEXT MESSAGES OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE.
JONES' LEGAL TEAM TRIED TO
ACTUALLY STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING, ASKED THE JUDGE TO
HAVE THE MATERIAL DESTROYED AND
THE JUDGE SAID IN RESPONSE I'M
NOT STANDING BETWEEN YOU AND
CONGRESS TO THE ATTORNEYS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> IT WAS A VERY UNUSUAL RULING
BY THE JUDGE.
USUALLY WHEN MATERIALS HAD BEEN
ACCIDENTALLY DISCLOSED TO THE
OTHER SIDE, THIS HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME IN BIG LAWSUITS WHERE
SOMEBODY SENDS TROVE OF
DOCUMENTS THAT WAS SENT IN
MISTAKE.
USUALLY THE COURT WILL ISSUE A
PROTECTIVE ORDER THAT SAYS DON'T
PUBLICIZE THIS UNTIL WE
STRAIGHTEN OUT AND DUOTGO THROU
THE MATERIAL YOU SHOULD RECEIVE.
THIS JUDGE, I THINK, IS SO FED
UP WITH WHAT WENT ON AT THAT
TRIAL BY THE DEFENSE.
SHE SAID I DON'T CARE.
TURN IT OVER TO CONGRESS, AND IT
IS A TREASURE-TROVE, AND IF IT
TIES ALEX JONES TO DONALD TRUMP
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BIG
DEVELOPMENT IN THESE HEARINGS
GOING DOWN THE ROAD.
THAT TRAGEDY IN SANDY HOOK,
YOU'LL NEVER GET THAT OUT OF THE
MINDS OF VOTERS ACROSS AMERICA.
>> I MEAN, HOW IT CAME ABOUT WAS
VERY INTERESTING AND I THOUGHT
THE JUDGE'S MOVE WAS INTERESTING
AS WELL.
GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS.